das ist da drauf gefallen hallo mein
name ist so herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen herren den kanal
glaube ich alle weil die gegen die mit
jedem video und den trend sind das sind
nämlich die prank groß und da hab ich
mir jetzt mal gedacht irgendwie der
kanal genau so aus wie vom profi also
dass sie sind halt die videos die prank
bronze machen und die thumbnails dazu
und profi sieht das ganze so aus also
quasi genau gleich sogar mit der mimik
die seen sogar genauso aus wie der aber
das soll jetzt gar nicht das thema sein
also es gibt schon genug leute die
gezeigt haben dass die treibhaus alles
beklauen und das ist auch die franks und
weiter und so fort aber habe ich möchte
mich heute wirklich um etwas anderes
kümmern ich bin nämlich die videos von
denen so ein bisschen durchgegangen und
war auch alles egal
anhalt videos ich hab dann aber auf
jeden fall ein video entdeckt was mich
wirklich getriggert hat und zwar stand
dort 1000 km h fidget spinner schwimmt
auf wasser da haben die einmal den trend
genommen den früher gab mit den 1000 km
h heißen schwerte katana schwert womit
sachen durchgeschnitten wurden das haben
die glaube ich auch mehrmals kopiert und
andererseits haben sie noch fit bin
damit ins game gebracht also diese
kleinen teile die sich zu drehen und den
haben sie anscheinend hoch besteuern
nicht auf 1000 km h freunde 1000 km h
das wie schnell ist 1000 km h ein paar
sekunden später also natürlich bedeutet
die zahl 1000 km h halt 1000
zurückgelegte kilometer in einer stunde
das heißt in 60 minuten würde dieser
fische spinnen 1000 km h schon ist 1000
kilometer zurücklegen das heißt quasi
einmal circa vom ganz oben deutschland
bis nach ganz unten in einer stunde mal
so zum vergleich das schafft nicht mal
ein flugzeug die schallgeschwindigkeit
in trockenen luft von 20 grad beträgt
300 43,2 meter pro sekunde also 1000 236
km/h anscheinend ist der philips bilder
von denen fast genauso schnell wie
schallgeschwindigkeit
das hier ist das sammeln von dem video
der titel ist wie gesagt 1000 km h auf
bis zu 2,5
mai
als wenn das ding zweieinhalb millionen
aufrufe hat also das video hat dann
scheint wirklich zweieinhalb millionen
aufrufe 130000 likes auf 32.000 dislike
so kann man mal so stehen lassen bevor
wir uns das video anschauen analysieren
wir das ganze erst mal haben wir hier 1
2 3 4 5 6 werbeanzeigen ich halte
meistens drei rolls deswegen ist das
zwar schon viel aber noch immer nicht so
viel wie bibi oder seien indes wir
machen wenn wir die kommentare mal so
durchgehen sehen wie nur wird zum
vergleich 1000 kamen hat 1200 km h
schalke wird ja okay das habe ich ja
auch schon rausgestellt jetzt mal
ehrlich herr staeck realtors ist auf
youtube geworden zwei idioten die bären
auf ein plastikspielzeug werfen und
daher noch schreiben sie das erste mal
achterbahn fahren es gibt echt nur noch
müll auf youtube 90 prozent von content
kann man vergessen jeder macht die
gleichen scheiß challenges oder
beweisvideos trains reportagen oder
sonstwas york wahrscheinlich kein wollte
ich aber trotz mal loswerden schönen tag
trotzdem allen ihren männern hier ja
also die community ist auf jeden fall
auf deren seite wie wäre es wenn keiner
mehr diese videos anklickt dann landen
die sparte auf der straße 11 minuten
dummheit und langeweile leute bitte sagt
mir dass die beiden nicht wirklich
gedacht haben einen fitten er könnte auf
dem wasser gleiten ein auto schwimmt ja
auch nicht nur weil sich die reifen
schnell drehen ihr gebt euch die faust
mit 1000 km h in den arsch reingeholt
ihr seid echt die unterschicht von
youtube und das sagt sogar donald trump
also ich muss hier wirklich sagen die
ganzen kommentare sind wirklich negativ
also es gibt ihnen die haben die keine
community die die wirklich feiern habe
ich würde sagen freude wir schauen erst
mal das video an und gucken ob die
vielleicht doch recht haben
[Musik]
ok vor der szene mit dem wasser haben
sie natürlich ausgeschaltet das intro
also niemand zu beginn schon gesehen hat
haben die hier nicht nur das mit dem
wasser gemacht sondern auch das mit
einem ballon und sogar mit was mit einem
glas hatten die hier gerade also ja
anscheinend handelt das video nicht nur
von dem was wenn wir das video mal ein
bisschen durch switchen die mir schon an
die fit bin da von denen hier wie sie
teile beschleunigen
schaffen wir 5000 like hier wird ein
bisschen weiter beschleunigt dann sind
diese sind die bären auf einmal ist soll
verdammt ernst die schmeißen etwas auf
einen drehenden fisches bin also sie
drehen den viertels wenn das schweißen
etwas drauf und sagen dann wow das ist
darauf gewalt also jetzt weiß ich auf
jeden fall was der kommentar zu bedeuten
hatte mit von wegen die schreien sollten
wenn sie jetzt erst mal achterbahn
gefahren die machen hunderttausendste
monat warum warum warum das ding ist der
mensch weil du den finder da drauf
gedrückt hat
so
müsst euch das mal so
und da stehen zwei erwachsene männer ich
weiß nicht wie alt ich werde jetzt mal
irgendwie so hofft mitte 20 schätzen und
reiben fit spinner an früchten und
wundern
ich kenne ich persönlich falls sie das
video gerade sehen sollte aber das ist
kein neuer ernst sein das wünschen hier
immer noch so ein bisschen weiter durch
sie sehen hier wieder mit der mango hat
machen die irgendwas mit luftballons
jetzt sagen die wahrscheinlich gehe ja
irgendwas mit likes hier haben wir das
übrigens vor allem die machen das ganze
jahr mit sohn geriet
ja
1000 km h wahrscheinlich oder wir zeigt
er ihm sein
hier wie gehen wir dann weiter machen
irgendwas mit mehl hier vorne ist
irgendeine komische szene hier sind sie
jetzt einer badewanne angekommen der
blau fit ich bin nach den ausgedreht mit
dem ding
wasser h2o wagefeld zwar sei es wird
schon mal wieder so ein bisschen durch
jetzt mal einfach nach vorne wir sehen
schon jetzt haben die hier den finger
wieder am start
jetzt packen die dänin auf wasser nehmen
sich aber hier in anderen fische nach
der hellblau fitnessgerät meine damen
und herren ich glaube das ist schon fast
die letzte szene geht von den
ihr hund mensch werde das gedacht er
geht auch unter war immer damit
gerechnet also wenn wir noch ein
bisschen mehr das video sehen wir mal
wieder die 50.000 leute ich glaube ich
habe youtube endlich verstanden wenn man
so häufig wie möglich in seinem video
sagt dass eine like anzahl erreicht
werden muss das haben die wahrscheinlich
auch wieder von profi dann wird diese
leider erreicht also freunde schaffen
wir bei diesem video 500.000 like wow
das sage ich gleich noch mal 500 auf
live
sechs freunde wenn wir das schaffen dann
essigen stars sonst natürlich profitiert
dennoch
wieso macht in letzter zeit jeder
youtuber dass mit dieser glocke also ich
weiß nicht genau was das bringt
anscheinend wenn ihr mich beispielsweise
gerade abonniert habe mit ihr unter dem
video neben dem abonniert knopf eine
glocke und wenn die da drauf klickt
könnt ihr auf updates klicken und
macht das auch und wird vom rathaus like
freude 5000 leicht wie oft doch diesen
verdanken
also ja das ist auf jeden fall das video
von dem frank gross hier das einfügen
der angeblich wirklich 1000 km h spinnt
das jetzt die wahrheit ist wage ich
jetzt mal eher zu bezweifeln der sollen
angeblich auf dem wasser schwimmen das
video hat uns gezeigt dass das ganze
nicht der fall ist ich würde mal ganz
kurz sagen freunde weil ich ich hab
nämlich etwas wirklich was mir gerade so
spontan einfällt was wirklich ein witz
bin auf 1000 km h beschleunigen kann das
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so eine
scheiße fahrrad pumpe die die broncos
hier in ihrem video drin hatten sondern
das ist wirklich was was noch viel
krasser blasen kann lasen
ich würde sagen freunde ich wünsche
gleich mal zu einer dslr kamera und
bewege mich zum max weil das gerät steht
gerade bei ihnen zu hause in der wohnung
oder nehme ich einfach mal ein oder zwei
vierteln ermitteln dann werden wir
einfach mal schaut auch dieses gerät dem
finder hier auf 1000 km h hoch
beschleunigen kann und ob der dann im
wasser schwimmen kann nur wenige minuten
später ich bin jetzt bei marx angekommen
freunde hier sehen schon hier ist der
vierzylinder hier haben wir das
waschbecken ich würde sagen dass jetzt
erst mal die jüngsten eindrücke und
gefühle jetzt mal wasser in das becken
so das müsste jetzt auch schon reichen
weil da woher wir haben hier das wasser
das ist ganz normales wasser also ihr
können einmal rankommen und selber
fühlen ist ganz normales wasser mit
sandwiches batterie es schon gerne ganz
normale geschwindigkeit aber davon her
ich bin ja nicht ohne grund zu max
gelaufen wer enthüllt jetzt das
unfassbare geriet das diesem film geht
spinner auf 1.000 km h hoch
beschleunigen kartons war es das gerät
keine normale maschine die man irgendwie
aus irgendwelchen anderen videos kennen
sondern es ist eher maximizer maximizer
bridges genauen postina
vielleicht lag's daran dass er fit bin
ja schon ein bisschen vorbelastet war
ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal selber
zu drehen und jetzt gebe ich mal dem
hexenmeister hat das ding ja pustet
jetzt neben der kamera
okay wir lassen jetzt den patches bin ja
wieder in das wasser fällt mir das kann
auch zu hause kam hat seid ihr bereit
für diese reaktion aber immerhin etwas
weiß woran es liegt woran sie sind am
waschbecken er wird sie eine schale
geholt jetzt müssen wir diese schade
dass wasser einfüllen schon da haben wir
yeah
es bleibt kaum drauf es hat schon ein
bisschen mehr geklappt okay leute
irgendwer das jetzt bisher mit dem
maximum also nicht so richtig geklappt
deswegen würde ich sagen ich probiere
das jetzt einfach mal selber aus und
guckt ob ich vielleicht die macs im
gemeinsamen hinweise 1000 camper kräfte
haben wir ja alle hier im waschbecken
ist immer noch wasser drin was ich jetzt
einfach mal machen werden ist ich werde
diese matches bin annehmen ihr seht
schon der dreht sich schon jetzt werde
ich diesen film trainer einfach mal über
dem waschbecken freunde ihr seht schon
okay der film dreht sich lassen jetzt
fallen alter also plus funktioniert was
also ich bin der weltmeister junge hexen
auf dem markt würde mir die brille wenn
dieses video hier nicht 500.000 live
freunde 500.000 likes 500.000 von
500.000 wieviel ex 500.000 life freude
und außerdem wiegt renkhoff es in jedem
video 50 mal sagen wo wir sagen das
gesagt aktiv wirklich verdammte glock
ich weiß nicht was sie bringt aktiviert
sie einfach anbieter durch fest am 11
ihr findet jetzt hier um ein smiley
eingeleitet wenn er darauf könnte meine
kanal kostenlos abonnieren verpasste
durch keine videos mehr wenn ich schon
abonnent sein um die glocke aktivieren
da oben sind auf meinen job ein gemeldet
in denen jetzt auch findet will dazu
kaufen wie conti rund 500.000 like